[Musique]
ce trop demander un service ou ans en
mer pour changer on dirait des traces de
piqûres nous a signalé deux autres corps
à l'autre bout de la ville et les deux
ont les mêmes traces sur la nuque
les trois victimes sont morts quasiment
la même heure mais aux quatre coins de
la ville comment tu expliques ça
[Musique]
west sur liberty
salut thomas ce qu'est ce que vous
racontez
c'est ici que ça se passe
je me trouve dans le centre ville de
philadelphie en ce jour du neuvième
anniversaire de ce qu'on appelle les
meurtres de market street dans le
quartier
j'écoute c'est à dire comment ça ça
recommence
il faut vous venu voir sa police de
philadelphie vous avez déjà vu cette
femme je suis contente d'être voir il se
fait déchiqueter par un métro elle
revient à 9 ans plus tard
[Musique]
retrouvez la priorité absolue de tous
les services de police il faut car et de
poursuivre
je fais ça pour une bonne raison nous on
avance dans lesquelles elle leur montre
tu n'as aucune idée de ce qui va se
produire
si tu me tues maintenant le monde tel
que tu le connais disparaîtra
[Musique]
lieutenant pourquoi on est là
les zombies comme toujours sont rapides
où ils sont là alors tant mieux tu vas
faire ça
prochain arrêt les handballeurs qu'est
ce que fut un musée le commencement
qu'est ce que c'est
n'y a peut-être quelque chose qui gêne
mademoiselle k rowling ouais n'ayez pas
peur il se souvient comment où jouent à
chat et bien cette route de personnes
là-bas sans les cheveux
[Musique]
oh mon dieu
on va tous quoi est ce qu'on va tous
crever mademoiselle caroline ont des
parcs du jeu les zombies ne sont pas
réels
mon petit chez chopard est planté mon
travail consiste à vous protéger
tu as là
[Musique]
ce type de comportement est inacceptable
que cinq ans et si vous n'arrivez pas à
parler correctement un enfant de 5 ans
je vais devoir vous demander de
descendre du tracteur et d'aller à
attendre dans l'auto de ça
est-ce que tu meures soir je te reçois
question mais je te mets pas sur scène
je te mets 4 sur 5 parce que il ya des
grésillons aller
voici encore on l'a bien préserver la
planète les vôtres c'est municipaux sa
part commencé à examiner la qualité qui
vont virer du monde et qu'on fait rien
carrière le plus jeune joueur dont on va
pas se laisser faire
la révolte gronde la lutte se prépare
c'est la cuve maintenant à l'horizon
selon moi la permanence ils en font
ricard
je te quitte tu me quittes s'infléchit
regarde-toi affaire personne n'en voudra
l'effet décembre jean paul ii la section
nationale du syndicat gars moi j'ai fait
tous heures de train fait chier avec
leur grève a forcé c'est pour les
archives vous propose la grève du zèle
travailler tout le temps je suis régime
cette mesure mérite réflexion peuvent et
le vert si vous êtes pour ma mère me dit
si cette verte prétend que ça il faut
l'épouser si tu crois que c'est la femme
de sa vie
tout cela
dix équipes ont pas de 12 et pas
d'autres alors pourquoi en inde et
kaboul a pour rester à west à la mode à
l'intérieur pour rester anonyme je le
savais j'ai pas osé le dire il faut les
briser menu un seul coup
il faut le sucre et le gras et on
gagnera on est là anonyme or monsieur le
maire c'est que c'est du travail de
[ __ ] le bordel tout le temps et c'est
du boulot
et de montage d'un projet ni mon but
grâce aux dindons
forcer votre cou rené tu vas appelé me
fait rire hervé thiard et du lobby des
valeurs essentielles la fidélité vous et
la finlande s'entend bien en avait une à
ma famille l'engagement avait le mérite
le pragmatisme
si je suis reprends mon mari je suis à
vous c'est fou j'ai une chance au
conditionnel mais c'est
l'incompréhension vous dise à icloud
vous n'êtes pas en bourse sauf
challenger le veuf peut recommencer dans
des clubs qui finit la clairvoyance
marie une vie si les maris des femmes
qui ne plaît sont toujours des imbéciles
en pâtit il y avait monsieur a bataillé
vaud
où trouver les vraies valeurs du couple
dans
le temps
[Musique]
j'ai entendu crier
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un
[Musique]
gal pegi
j'ai passé un peu bizarre tout ça je
crois qu'on devrait revenir sur la route
beke crédit ce qui est vous qu'est-ce
qu'ils fassent
je voulais simplement vous retrouvez moi
comment tu as pu arriver ici avant nous
de faire mon fils et ma famille ils sont
perdus ou si c'était juste dans la
chaude jamais la retrouver on peut
retrouver des choses mais c'est plus
facile quand elles sont mortes
c'est dans ce champ depuis combien de
temps
[Musique]
j'ai plus trop
on aurait dit ma voix
ces cours corps ce délire oui tout est
délirante en quoi vous croyez que c'est
un hasard
on vient pas dans les airs de haute par
hasard
les possibles
c'est un choc
c'est juste gens
les rumeurs infondées
c'était la moitié des humains
à moitié des belges ce sont des sortes
bête qui mordent et boivent le sang des
humains les amis nous allons renverser
le monde le sait
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
c'est bien aidé si je peux oui vous
l'avez trouvé où ce gamin dans les cinq
premiers avoir recruté du premier coup à
wall street
excusez moi mais mon travail c'est la
conformité des hasards vous avez fait
enregistrer ce rapport est empêché par
là même une entreprise pesant plus de 7
milliards de dollars de faire affaire
avec nous on veut réaffectant région
dans une des nos succursales
elle bat à new york c'est là que j'ai
quand tu peux par là je devrais pas voir
ça au contraire il faut que tu vois ça
qu'est-ce qui nous voient le plaisir tu
là pour parler aux propriétaires faut
que tu vois ça marty bonne numéro de
téléphone pas dit mais juste une boîte à
remplir 10 millions c'est pas un petit
investissement
il me semblait que c'était and it
saloperies genre terrorisme trafics
d'armes trafic d'êtres humains est bien
un mec je te vois partout tu me suivent
quoi ouais marqua un [ __ ] de vrais
problèmes je suis pratiquement sûr que
la mafia russe blanchi de l'argent via
la succursale de mener
pas si mal
[Musique]
tc quoi tuer les héros